[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever
we want hey we got dante back
what's up and we never really get to
film talk you never get the film talk
what's your favorite [ __ ] movie of
all time all time
what is it a time uh before you say it
what's your favorite movie of all time
if you could make
any movie what would it be your dream
movie like what movie
you're confusing the story the question
now no no just two it's two questions
what's your favorite movie of all time
and i want to know why right and then
the other one is
that's three questions what other movie
that has already been made
that you wished it was said directed by
dante bosco the worst
like a big jacket or like a
tight-fitting jacket
no so i'm telling tiff it's not a weird
question my second question a weird
question because in
the comedy world or even like in the
creative world sometimes an
idea is so good you go man i wish i came
up with that so that's what you mean
that's what i mean though so what movie
is so good like [ __ ] i wish i did that
and that's so great i've been thinking a
lot of movies lately because i
during the whole covered year i've been
watching movies with my girlfriend and
we started doing a live stream every
monday called monday cinema club
and we just watched movie classics
that's awesome i'm jealous
it's very cool monday movie monday yeah
we've been i think we've done like 48
now
oh wow wow the thing is you go back to
your favorite movie is it just youtube
just us
but then we watch the family we bring
fans in so now these all the fans do you
watch the movie together and then talk
about it after we watch the movies
during the week and then we discuss it
like a book club with fans and people
just kind of chime in all over the world
and we just they it's weird because they
start watching movies with you have all
these teenagers watching
do you let them know ahead of time yeah
every week we tell them what the next
movie is
your favorite movie is the johnny depp
willy wonka movie no no
although the original willy wonka movie
is amazing
i always say my favorite movie you know
growing up because i was really steady
acting was
a play movie called a place in the sun
with montgomery cliff and
and elizabeth taylor which i'm sure you
guys never did was a great movie
never seen it but then you watch it
again this is george stevens this is
like
mid 50s and like scorsese would say like
you don't have to go to film school just
watch
george stevens the place inside it's
really this really beautiful movie and
montgomery clift is like a kind of actor
that brando everyone's chasing him at
that turn time so i really love the
movie but watching it now
during a different era it's like really
a place in the sun
yeah really beautiful but elizabeth
taylor super hot in that movie yeah
young and beautiful
so what's your favorite movie man but i
mean
you just said well that was my favorite
movie growing up because i really loved
montgomery cliff as a young actor but i
mean
if you watch a movie uh watching
godfather against perfect movie
oh i knew it godfather's perfect movie
but then there's certain things i like
princess bride
perfect movie prince's bride is [ __ ]
awesome but matrix
perfect movie really good yeah
especially two
i'm just kidding for one you start
watching movies like what you're like
that's a [ __ ] perfect movie what
about die hard
i haven't seen that in a while but i
love that movie in a while i love
i love dying diet one yeah during one
yeah no it's great
it's great i haven't seen it in at least
ten years but it's beautiful that's not
reaching corporation
yeah i live right by the building really
oh yeah
well what about the one that you wish
you would have you made yeah his second
question
uh just so i know what your voice is as
an artist
you know i thought again go you go back
and you go to movie that you really
thought i would thought i would want to
make a movie like high fidelity you'll
watch high fidelity
oh wait i'm john cusack all right john
cusack
in that movie uh i don't know her name
she's like from another country
but like at least bonnie's in it and
it's like a really cool movie about this
guy who owns a record store in real
indie very kind of like
a lot of conversation and really cool
thoughts and he's talking to the camera
a lot i i thought i would like want to
make that movie but then you watch that
movie you know there's all these like
very
new in this whole time of social justice
you go oh yeah that's kind of messed up
it's
actually interesting to watch for young
people that looking at a movie that you
loved 20 years ago and they're like
that dude's an [ __ ] you're like i
guess you're right
it's like when they watch heather's now
they were trying to cancel the movie
heathers
how do you cancel these i think you can
appreciate them for the time they are
and then thinking it to remake it now
you can never have that
but heathers wasn't glorifying this [ __ ]
no no but it was the fact that they went
there
it was cancelable in in the eyes of uh
eminem too
so all right but like a high fidelity
because he's like
my dude keeps calling the girl over and
over again she's like leave me alone
leave me like he keeps calling her and
[ __ ] and i was like i don't know just
like taming the shrew bro
it's like this like i'll change this
chat yeah right so
but i mean i think we can also progress
and think like
we're not trapped in you know yeah true
what about these movies you like the
most like like dissecting
the elements of these movies no it's
just performance and
romance i like romance i like dialogue i
like
interesting characters kind of thing i
mean so you like trolls
very safe very safe answers you don't
like seeing what you know i see someone
getting that aspect
tell me how much you like blood sport oh
that's smart
well some of you were van damme is
dancing with those chicks like a [ __ ]
weird boxer
kickboxing
oh i love [ __ ] the commentary movie
frank dukes um yeah not like action
films somebody just think though you
asked me those questions
that's where they came have you made an
action film yet
uh yep i'm never in the action part of
it
you know so what's the movie that you
wish was your movie
like that was like oh man i wish i was
like like got
like good fellas or like godfather oh
yeah like yeah like that was
it high fidelity not me yeah like kind
of like romantically i mean there's also
movies growing up like
you wish like oh like love jones i wish
i would've done love jones or something
i don't know that one it's like it's
filmed like chicago same poetry both
from chicago must have a thing for
chicago stuff
what about chicago but also i saw
another movie recently that
when the movie that i did wrote inspired
a lot of what we did it was moonstruck
was awesome and it's like really you
know italian new york but then the movie
i directed
a lot of the ideas and stuff that john
patrick's channel is on that movie we
were kind of like
stealing some stuff i see so it's a very
slice of life yeah i'm more like a
character driven
if i'm gonna make a movie i'm like more
about character-driven dialogue
kind of fun things usually around love
i mean i like a lot of you know what's
your movie call by the way real quick
uh the fabulous filipino brothers
by the way congratulations joe's in it
joe's in it
joe plays him did you get to see your
stuff yeah it's [ __ ] dope you like
you
you you killed it yeah congrats yeah
thank you seriously yeah
thank you for letting me be on it man it
was [ __ ] dope yeah yeah yeah how come
i wasn't in it yeah why not bart though
and and and why didn't bart's screen
test i was like i was a plan b
too guys so don't worry about it he
wrote it for someone else and he didn't
show up so i came in and
come out with some plants either but
bart auditioned for it 14 times what
happened what happened
joe killed me i didn't even have to
audition he just called me
oh wow one second we're going to see
this movie nowhere yeah
just can i give him the links no don't
give them another one
you get
can we watch it as a group yeah because
we saw a little portion of it joe has a
link
what are we gonna have a screening we
could do that can we have a super small
and then we gotta
we gotta have a director's like q and a
after and you're gonna be there with
them i don't know if it's all that
serious but yeah yeah yeah
so what's your favorite movie so uh
what's this after studio so this is this
is
so this has been happening right where
like i loved watching classics like the
stuff that i grew up on
but now i would watch these and even if
it's a comedy i get sad
it's [ __ ] weird really what yeah like
it could be like it could be like tommy
boy it could be like home alone from
your childhood
yeah all these things like top gun or
whatever right i love these movies but
then i watch it and i'm just what's
making you say
top gun i mean goose goose that's really
sad
part of it makes you sad boy he's dead
the nostalgia makes me
feel sad like that this is an era that's
gone
instead of like before it would be like
i'm i'm watching it and i'm like oh yeah
i'm reliving it or it's just this oh
this is cool right
but now it's like this uh nostalgia
where i am that
six-year-old or whatever watching it and
it's so [ __ ] weird man i get these
like reminiscent feelings
and i can't sometimes i can't finish the
movie yeah what's your favorite movie
it's like going to the old neighborhood
i get some of those feelings like when i
watch videos of isaac being a little
baby and i get really sad that i won't
ever know that kid again
so it's similar ish my favorite movie i
mean i always had this one answer
that because i i just love so many
different movies that it's really hard
for me to put
boil it down to one three of them
no i don't even i haven't put that much
thought to even come up with like a top
three top five seven
but the one movie that i always say
though and i stick to because i [ __ ]
love this movie
is cat in the hat with mike myers oh my
god that's an interesting choice comedy
in that movie is just so [ __ ] spot on
for me
i [ __ ] cat in the hat yeah no one's
ever said it was what i love about it
i've never heard canton hat
i love that you say godfather it's like
whatever yeah we all know god bless yeah
yeah no but that's like my
my go-to answer but like there's
obviously so many other movies that are
more serious that i can like appreciate
the beauty of
hey [ __ ] them that's your favorite movie
whatever it means to use like what's
your favorite book it's like whatever
the [ __ ] you like
i found this old hat you're you're just
cat in the hat
dude like i i just [ __ ] love that
movie i love like
all the lines in it all the jokes and
you quote the entire thing i haven't
even seen it so i
it's that movie and matilda like those
two movies are my [ __ ]
favorite movies you know danny devito
directed matilda yeah oh yeah
he's like narrator he's like the nicest
narrator voice and then he's like the
shittiest dad character in the movie too
yeah
so those are my two go-to's but there's
been so many great movies
it's hard to choose what up guys this
video is brought to you by
hello fresh in case you guys don't know
what it is
it is a meal delivery service that comes
with
pre-packaged ingredients fresh
ingredients that you get to make
at home and all the recipes are 30
minutes or less and if you're looking to
save money which i think everyone's
trying to save money these days
you're in luck because did you know with
hellofresh on average you save
28 more on your groceries it makes sense
because what happens when you go
and then you got an idea like i want to
make some spaghetti
and you get all of these ingredients
right i'm gonna make
a whole burger and you get all these
ingredients
but you're just one person yeah and then
what what you're gonna do you're gonna
eat burgers
every single day maybe you're gonna eat
12 patties you [ __ ] yeah
maybe yeah but what's gonna end up
happening is that's gonna go bad in the
fridge man and that's a lot of food
waste yep and not only that
you're spending thirty dollars to make
one hamburger
that's true i never realized that but
anyways um
hello fresh is pretty awesome because
not only that they have like over 25
recipes
and i had an opportunity to try some
myself
it's pretty dang good man yeah yeah and
you actually feel good about it because
you made it
so you're like i made this thing that i
would never have made before
alaskan salmon with freaking thyme or
whatever the hell it is
so make sure if you want to go try so if
you want to go try your own recipes try
to cook
and not have food waste and save 28 on
your groceries go to hellofresh.com use
the code off the record
12 because you get 12 free meals it's
not crazy now you have no reason
to be mealless yeah okay off the record
12
12 free meals at hellofresh.com see you
guys next time it's america's number one
male kid baby and they get mushrooms
from us too so
thanks a lot hello fresh
um butt sport nah so that's what's my
favorite childhood movie it's like your
go-to answer like my favorite it's my
favorite goat i mean it's my favorite
childhood movie
and if i see it on i don't even need to
look around
what else is there you can just click it
yeah um i think my favorite
my a movie that i wished i would made
would be like glorious bastards
i really like that um i really like
kung fu hustle i love coco
i like uh i think like like everyone
likes good fellas
or casino what was that comfortable like
you can't even say you wish you made it
it's like there's no way i can make that
movie it's just two this is
true no one could have made that movie
other than stephen chow yeah his brain
is just on another level
bizarre it's so bizarre so good like i
can't do that i
would never be able to do that yeah and
like just the world building is just
how do you pitch that honey we're going
to make a kung fu movie
and there's going to be a road runner
scene no you go i'm stephen ciao
we make it okay whatever you want man
what's your favorite movie about yours
so i gotta say it's a tie for me and
that sucks i hate that [ __ ] but
ghostbusters and the original one yeah
the original one and big lebowski
that was fun yeah those are those two
just kill me
i love those movies they used to be one
of your answers the big lebowskis
lebowski's up there for me yeah
that to me is the cohen's best they're
they're geniuses everything they do is
so good but that one i don't think they
missed a single comedic beat
like at all like from beginning to end i
gotta watch it's been like forever since
i've seen that movie
it's one of those movies where i watched
it when with my father in 19
whenever it came out like 96 or some
[ __ ] he brought it home from vhs nobody
ever heard of it it was like an
underground thing
it was an underground comedy film and i
watched it with my dad it was one of the
first times because i was like you know
i don't know
like 11 and my dad was like let's watch
this it's okay you'll be fine and it
just made me feel like such a man i got
to watch the movie where people were
saying the bad words and stuff
and i was also laughing my ass off with
him like we laughed so hard that we
couldn't breathe
at many points yeah so i just have such
a fond memory for that movie no it's
crazy my little brother one is like
part-time gigs he's the property manager
for the house for the big lebowski
and hung out the manchester united yeah
the manager oh sick
like just kick it at the crib i love all
the stories you make up
this guy thinks he knows celebrities
they [ __ ] know these things yeah my
brother's at the property manager for
the house they still shoot there
obviously so he'll he'll like be the
property manager sometimes and then
something over there he's like let's go
hang out there we play tennis on that
tennis court what
that's awesome dude i love uh taiko ytt
movies they're so
funny these are great beautiful like
they're so funny but they're also like
hit the heart they hit the heart like
so good i feel like you would if you
could uh make
someone's other movie probably a taiko
movie yeah i i would i would
there's a heavy emphasis which one of
those you think oh jojo
oh no oh boy i really like like so good
if you go deep into taika and my tt's
that's the one that i think he did that
was like [ __ ] perfect and i found it
everyone's boy boys
the the kid and then the grandpa dad was
locked up and he finally came back
character yeah
it's i wish you're like thor ragnarok
for me personally like yes
is amazing no i know but it's so that's
the best thor movie for sure
sound wise it's hilarious the best
marvel movie it's really good thor
ragnarok it's true it's up there
true but yeah you know it's a good movie
though whenever uh
like the way i found boy right like my
story for that movie would be
i was just i was cooking and i was like
i'm gonna throw something on in the
background
and then i turned on i was like what the
[ __ ] this movie some indie film never
heard the director's name whatever you
know i was like just turn it on
and then you're cooking and then it
starts and you're just kind of like
okay all right first act and you kind of
just sit down
and you watch the entire [ __ ] thing
without ever going back to cooking
and then you're your thing's on fire
yeah and the whole thing's burnt
and it almost burns down around you into
a cinder but that's a [ __ ] good movie
you know
like that we're all in flames
[Laughter]
that's what she hoped happened on
netflix most of the time and that never
happened never happened i was just like
[ __ ] i just wasted an hour and a half of
my life
i love so many movies back to the future
for sure
good call gladiator for sure gladiators
uh gang's in new york uh man all of
scorsese stuff if i had to choose
one it'd be casino but i love casino the
best you know that's my favorite one of
his yeah
for me i watch based off of mood you
know true either better or worse
depending on how you feel
but man i think it's so hard to narrow
down one for me it can't you can't do it
fight club was my
my all-time favorite a movie a movie
that i wish i made
because i think at the end of the day i
just want to have fun
it's probably like an ocean's eleven oh
yeah that's just a fun
world ocean's eleven was solid perky
music
cool storyline you don't know what the
hell's happening and you're just
having like it just seems like
everyone's having fun the whole time
yeah yeah
you know they're all having i mean dude
they're all just dunking checks and
laughing yeah
don cheadle's just like [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah well
the i think the part of the charm about
ocean's 11 2 is like
the heavy hitters yeah like the original
one was with the rat pack
and there was those guys you know that's
true it's like the legacy of that story
with the rat pack and then recreating it
i didn't know it wasn't recreated oh
yeah frank sinatra and
yeah yeah i want to watch that martin
martin sam davis james davis jr the
whole crew and i love a good heist movie
but then i like it with
that kind of style that real rat pack
had the the crew like think about they
were doing these movies together they
all had their individual
stardom careers and then they go to
vegas and did they do a show together
on stage and for the audience party all
over vegas
they were like a legit clique like super
group do whatever the [ __ ] they want to
do
like no they can't even do that anymore
like can you imagine like oh we haven't
we have to show them
you guys you're on vegas and we're gonna
[ __ ] party people
there's gonna be people come to see us
[ __ ] around for like two hours just
doing whatever playing piano whatever
sing dance whatever then we'll go party
after it's a variety show
variety show so we can really do
whatever you want to do sammy wants to
dance
you want to sing a two-minute sketch
whatever
we'll drink on stage what's crazy is
back in those days you were sitting next
to
mobsters and killers and stuff in the
audience and people went to vegas
for that reason is i want to sit next to
this hey i was with tony soprano dude do
you know about this guy killed so and so
and then they go back to like it's crazy
because that's when suburban people
for entertainment would go to vegas for
that reason
and at that time vegas was nothing like
you flew into this thing and there was
that
and then started dead and then if you
got taken a desert you're you're gone
that's [ __ ] crazy with that click and
they got new movies together it was so
cool
that's why i like casino the most out of
the scorsese stuff because i love old
vegas
old vegas has such a magic to it yeah
and when i see it like in filmography
i'm like [ __ ]
i wish this was real classy that's
really you could still go visit it but
there's a bunch of homeless guys at neon
leotards over there
talking about what's that what's the
downtown area called free monster
street but in the same way that like you
know once upon a time in hollywood
like i guess shows you old hollywood you
can experience it i guess by going to
the circus liquor store but it's not the
same like yeah and then they have this
stupid zipline thing that kind of like
goes across that street now
stupid is really fun i got stuck in the
middle of it i haven't done it
no but like it ruins the nostalgia like
it
was just kind of there now there's like
a thing that just hovers above you're
like
you could go to nine ninety-five pokemon
back then and you go to the pokemons
downtown it feels
like old school it feels so old though
that it's the guys from that era that
are just washed up and on the table and
they never left hey just wait
though cause like what we're talking
about right now like will happen to like
the moon
you'll go to an apollo 11 exhibit and
you'll be on the moon and you're looking
at things under glasses like i guess
those are the
aren't the the the footprints and all
the [ __ ] and there's the module and
[ __ ] and just like whatever like it was
better back then
it's better when neil armstrong was
there
and they're gonna have a zip line all
right so commercial out it's our error
of whatever
is there our error of anything gonna
matter no everything gets old we will be
right now he was saying like right now
it is so [ __ ] hard to like
tantalize people making p and make
people go wow it was it was so much
easier back in the day because you put a
[ __ ] volcano in front of your hotel
and everyone comes to see it now it's
like you got to do a movie
[ __ ] wow yeah now you got [ __ ] a
volcano in front of a casino but david
blaine's trying to freeze himself alive
over there
and this is like oh [ __ ] what are we
gonna do and chris angel's like floating
i guess
on the street with magnets he's still
relevant he's trying to be
it's like chris affliction is over dude
you